highly creative people have found that
very often they have multiple projects
in progress at the same time and they're
also far more likely than most of us to
have serious Hobbies slow motion
multitasking feels like a
counterintuitive idea but the reason it
seems counterintuitive is because we're
used to lapsing into multitasking out of
desperation we're in a hurry we want to
do everything at once if we were willing
to slow multitasking down we might find
that it works quite brilliantly
creativity often comes when you take an
idea from its original context and you
move it somewhere else it's easier to
think outside the box if you spend your
time clambering from one box into
another